sur ces images amateures on aperçoit au
loin la fin du parcours d'un avion en
train de tomber à pic des cris de
surprise et une énorme explosion qui
secoue cette partie de la région russe
de Belgorod à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de la frontière
ukrainienne rapidement des premiers
éléments sont donnés par le ministère
russe de la Défense repris peu après par
un député de la Doua président de la
Commission de la
Défense à bord se trouvai 65 anciens
militair des forces armées ukrainiennes
prisonniers de guerre qui étent emmenés
pour être échangé les dirigeants
Ukrainiens étaient parfaitement au
courant de l'échange à venir et avaiit
été informé de la manière dont les
prisonniers seraient livrés mais l'avion
il76 a été abattu par trois
missiles outre les prisonniers
Ukrainiens six membres d'équipage et
trois accompagnateurs se trouvaient
selon Moscou à bord de l'avion de
transport militaire il76 comme celui-ci
le gouverneur de Belgorod annonce qu'il
n'y aurait aucun survivant toujours
selon la Russie un autre appareil du
même type le suivait avec 80 autres
prisonniers et aurait fait demi-tour
pour les députés russes aucun doute les
missiles aurait été lancé par l'armée
ukrainienne ils ont tué dans les air
leurs propres
soldats leurs mèr leurs femmes leurs
enfants les
attendaient ils ont utilisé des missiles
américains et
allemands côté ukrainien personne n'a
confirmé jusqu'ici l'existence de cet
échange de prisonniers qui régulièrement
notamment à l'aide de drone cette région
de belgorot depuis quelques semaines